Drew! What are you doing here?
Hannah invited me. You look great, by the way. I
love your shirt made of pogs. Are those Pogs?
Whatever they are, I love them to death.
Are you okay?
Why wouldn't I be okay? Because you dumped
me? Or because my dad's probably going to
prison till I'm 50. Or because I got buzzed
alone on Oat Milk White Russians in my
apartment earlier today and then just
wandered aimlessly around Midtown until I saw
a day spa advertising a "Glow-up Teeth
Whitening and Spray Tan Special" for $49.99
called The Orange Creamsicle and said to
myself, "I deserve that".
Did you get a spray tan? So natural I hadn't
noticed.
Sorry. Sorry.
Once in a while I get these shooting pains in
my two front teeth. They say it happened to one in
100 people who go to New York Upstairs
Whitening and Tan. Guess I'm one of the lucky ones.
I think I've got an Advil for you.
No, it's all good. The receptionist gave me a couple codeine
in exchange for a kiss.
Hey, I'm Ian.
What's up? I'm Drew.
It's my ex, Sophie.
Don't waste this fun energy on us, Drew, go
congratulate the happy couple.
Good point. Hey, if you need me, just follow
the light.
Ooh, do I smell gefilte fish?